I was the first woman president
of an African nation.
And I do believe more countries
ought to try that.
(Laughter)
(Applause and cheers)
Once the glass ceiling has been broken,
it can never be put back together --
however one would try to do that.
When I assumed the presidency of Liberia
in January 2006,
we faced the tremendous challenges
of a post-conflict nation:
collapsed economy,
destroyed infrastructure,
dysfunctional institutions,
enormous debt,
bloated civil service.
We also faced
the challenges of those left behind.
The primary victims of all civil wars:
women and children.
On my first day in office,
I was excited ...
and I was exhausted.
It had been a very long climb
to where I was.
Women had been those who suffered most
in our civil conflict,
and women had been the ones to resolve it.
Our history records
many women of strength and action.
A President of the United Nations
General Assembly,
a renowned circuit court judge,
a president of the University of Liberia.
I knew that I had to form
a very strong team
with the capacity to address
the challenges of our nation.
And I wanted to put women
in all top positions.
But I knew that was not possible.
And so I settled for putting them
in strategic positions.
I recruited a very able economist
from the World Bank
to be our minister of finance,
to lead our debt-relief effort.
Another to be the minister
of foreign affairs,
to reactivate our bilateral
and multilateral relationships.
The first woman chief of police
to address the fears of our women,
who had suffered so much
during the civil war.
Another to be the minister of gender,
to be able to ensure the protection
and the participation of women.
Over time,
the minister of justice,
the minister of public works,
the minister of agriculture,
the minister of commerce and industry.
Participation in leadership
was unprecedented in my administration.
And although I knew
that there were not enough women
with the experience
to form an all-women cabinet --
as I wanted --
I settled to appoint numerous women
in junior ministerial positions,
as executives,
as administrators,
in local government,
in diplomatic service,
in the judiciary,
in public institutions.
It worked.
At the end of 2012,
our economic growth
had peaked at nine percent.
Our infrastructure was being
reconstructed at a very fast pace.
Our institutions were functioning again.
Our debt of 4.9 billion
had been largely canceled.
We had good relationships
with the International Monetary Fund,
the World Bank,
the African Development Bank.
We also had good working relationships
with all our sister African countries
and many nations all over the world.
Our women could sleep
peacefully at night again,
without fear.
Our children were smiling again,
as I promised them during
my first inaugural address.
The reputation and credibility
of our nation,
lost in the many years of conflict,
were restored.
But progress is never guaranteed.
And in our legislature, in my first term,
women were 14 percent.
In the second term,
it declined to eight percent,
because the environment
was increasingly toxic.
I had my fair shares
of criticism and toxicity.
Nobody is perfect.
But there's nothing more predictable
than a strong woman
who wants to change things,
who's brave to speak out,
who's bold in action.
But I'm OK with the criticism.
I know why I made the decisions I made,
and I'm happy with the results.
But that's why more women
leaders are needed.
For there will always be those
who will tear us down,
who will tear us apart,
because they want
the status quo to remain.
Although sub-Saharan Africa
has had major breakthroughs
in women's leadership and participation,
particularly in the legislature --
in parliament, as it's called --
so many women,
50 percent and over, one of our nations,
well over 60 percent,
the best in the world --
but we know that's not enough.
While we must be very thankful
and applaud the progress we have made,
we know that there is much
more work to be done.
The work will have to address
the lingering vestiges
of structural ...
something against women.
In too many places,
political parties
are based on patronage,
patriarchy,
misogyny
that try to keep women
from their rightful places,
that shut them out
from taking leadership positions.
Too often, women face --
while the best performers,
while equal or better in competence --
unequal pay.
And so we must continue to work
to change things.
We must be able to change
the stereotyping.
We must be able to ensure
that those structural barriers
that have kept women
from being able to have the equity
they rightfully deserve.
And we must also work with men.
Because increasingly,
there is recognition
that full gender equity
will ensure a stronger economy,
a more developed nation,
a more peaceful nation.
And that is why we must continue to work.
And that is why we're partners.
I will be launching a Center
for Women and Development
that will bring together --
(Applause)
women who have started
and are committed
to their joining of leadership.
With women who have excelled
and advanced in leadership together.
Over a 10-year period,
we strongly believe
that we will create this wave of women
who are prepared to take,
unabashedly,
intentional leadership and influence
throughout society.
This is why --
(Laughs)
at 81, I cannot retire.
(Applause and laughter)
(Applause and cheers)
Women are working for change
in Africa.
throughout the world.
I will be with them,
and one of them,
forever.
(Applause)
Thank you for listening.
Go out and change the world.
(Applause and cheers)